VERA: OK, so thanks,
everyone, for coming.
My name is Vera.
Myself and Verne head
up Talks at Google
for the Toronto office.
This is our second installment.
We're sticking on this
charity [INAUDIBLE].
I love it very much.
So we have Dr. Samantha
Nutt from War Child
here with us today.
Adam Green, as you
all know, who's
from the agency team
who's the creative lead,
he will be hosting.
And welcome.
Thank you for coming.
If you do have any questions,
please walk up to the mics
as there are people on
the live stream and we're
recording this.
Thank you.
ADAM GREEN: Awesome.
Thanks, Vera.
And welcome, Samantha.
SAMANTHA NUTT: Thank you.
Happy to be here.
ADAM GREEN: Thanks for
coming in to Google.
So for those who aren't
familiar with your work,
if you could tell
us a little bit
about what is War
Child and the work
that you guys do
around the world.
SAMANTHA NUTT: So War
Child is an international
non-governmental
organization and charity.
And we work with children
and their families
on the front lines of
most of the world's
most significant and
intense conflicts.
So essentially what we are
is we're a protection agency.
So we go into
environments to work
with those kids
and their families
to make sure that they are safe,
that their needs are being met,
and that they have opportunities
to rebuild their lives
and rebuild their communities
over the long term.
The ways in which we do
that, what we focus on,
we have three pillars.
So one is education, making
sure that kids in war
are allowed to maintain
their education,
catch up on their education,
and grow to be thriving members
of their community.
The second part of what we
do-- it sounds a bit technical,
but it's justice work.
And so we make sure that
especially in environments
where girls and young boys
can be sexually assaulted,
where their rights are
routinely being violated,
we work to actually promote
and uphold the rule of law
by training lawyers
and paralegals,
defending the rights
of those children
actively within
those communities,
but also through the legal
infrastructure if one exists.
And then the third
part of what we
do we call opportunity, which
is really about making sure
that families are
economically self-reliant
and have the opportunity to
provide for themselves to try
to break that cycle
of aid dependency
that plagues so many
humanitarian catastrophes
around the world,
but just making sure
that those families have
resources at their own disposal
to be able to make the right
kinds of decisions that
will be suitable for them
and for their children.
ADAM GREEN: That's
fantastic work.
SAMANTHA NUTT: Thank you.
ADAM GREEN: So you work
in some of the most
miserable and dangerous
places in the world, places
where there is effectively
active war going on.
And most of what we
hear is, how do they
get emergency aid-- enough
sutures, enough water,
enough plasma in there.
How do you guys get
in books, and lawyers,
and actually work with people on
building longer, better lives?
SAMANTHA NUTT:
Well, I think Adam
you've hit on a really
good point, which
is that when we
think about crises
in other parts of the world, and
especially war, unfortunately
our memories are pretty short.
And so we think about
the emergency phase--
so food, water, shelter,
blankets, vaccination programs,
the things that you need
to keep people alive.
But people also need
reasons to live.
And when wars drag on
as they so frequently
do-- if you look at
the war in Syria now,
it's in its sixth year.
The war in Sudan has been,
apart from a few moments
where it hasn't been as
intense, has been going on
for many decades now.
Other parts of the
Middle East, if you
look at the eastern Congo where
it's nearly 20 years, Somalia
where it's multiple decades,
as those wars drag on,
those gaps and those needs
become that much more enormous.
And unfortunately, our
capacity to remain involved
and demonstrate compassion
tends to dwindle
as those conflicts drag on.
And unfortunately, that's when
the needs become even greater.
Because you've got kids who have
been out of school for 5, 6,
10 years.
You've got families
that have completely
drained all of their
financial resources,
that have lost their land,
lost their livelihoods.
You have a legal infrastructure,
a protective environment
that has essentially been
destroyed where there may not
be any police.
There may not be a functioning
judicial infrastructure.
So if your rights
are being violated,
if you're being raped and
abused, you have no recourse.
And so that's what
War Child focuses on.
And in order to
do that, you have
to mobilize those
local communities.
You have to make
sure that they have
the skills and the capacity
to be able to do the work,
that they have the resources.
And fundamentally,
you have to make sure
that you have a
long-term vision.
War is a long-term problem.
And by continuing to
only plug those gaps,
we aren't, I think,
fundamentally
addressing the reasons why
some of these communities
tend to be locked in that
cycle of violence and poverty,
and frankly, despair
in the first place.
ADAM GREEN: So you mentioned
the war in the Congo.
We had the good fortune of
having Malala Yousufzai's
parents here the other week.
And he mentioned that
the children that
are sitting in camps today,
getting no education,
they are the ISIS of tomorrow.
They are the wars of tomorrow.
They are the
terrorists of tomorrow.
The DRC came to be one of the
worst wars in modern history.
There are an estimated 7 1/2
million kids there who are
getting no education.
Is that really the
demographic time
bomb that Malala's
dad was fearing?
SAMANTHA NUTT:
Certainly, it is true
that kids who have almost
nothing in environments
where there is a tremendous
amount of violence, where there
is recruitment that's going
on by various armed groups,
militia groups-- in
the case of the Congo,
it's an inordinate number of
people that are recruiting
and abducting young
people to fight
in that conflict in a
climate of absolute impunity.
So certainly, young
people who are unemployed,
who are not in school, who have
witnessed horrific abuses, who
have been the victims of
horrific abuses themselves,
they are certainly more
vulnerable to that level
of recruitment, to that
kind of ideological pull
that many of those armed
groups will offer them.
I mean, War Child
knows, even for the work
that we have done
all around the world,
that when we have
done skills training
with young people, when we
have worked with teachers
and other educators to make
sure that they had access
to education, could go back to
school at an appropriate grade
level-- because if you're
17 and you've been fighting
with the militia
group in eastern Congo
and you're functionally
illiterate,
you don't want to go back
to being in grade one
with a bunch of six-year-olds.
I mean, that's
humiliating for you.
So it becomes a huge barrier.
So yes, education is
critically important.
It's not the only thing, though.
Economic development becomes
critically important.
Making sure that their
psychological needs are being
addressed and that
overarching framework
of a lack of accountability is
one of the biggest challenges,
too.
ADAM GREEN: Yeah, you're make in
your book a pretty strong case
that on the Venn
diagram of humanity
where cheap, small arms and
idle young men intersect
is a recipe for war.
So bringing education
in hopefully
pulls the idle young men
out of that equation.
But how far can you
get when AK-47s cost
$10 in a lot of these places?
Education is a huge part.
What about arms control?
SAMANTHA NUTT: Arms control
is absolutely critical.
And I think that it's
especially important right now
that we talk about this issue.
When you look at the rise
of ISIS in the Middle East,
if you look at even the
devastating attacks that
have taken place in
the United States,
even in Orlando, Florida,
the easy availability
of automatic and
semi-automatic weapons--
small arms more generally--
creates both opportunity
and means for those
who seek to destroy
and harm to be able to do so.
And the proliferation
of small arms,
especially in
unstable environments,
is I think one of the
single greatest threats
to public health and global
peace and security in existence
in the world today.
We have seen a dramatic increase
in the sale of those arms
and the manufacturing of
those weapons since September
11th over the past now
more than 15 years.
And so if you have a
lawless environment where
there is very little
employment where
you've got half the
population roughly
that is under the age of
30, and in some cases,
under the age of
18, you are going
to have a situation
where people will take up
arms to resolve grievances,
to earn an income,
and to express their will and
their particular ideology.
So the arms, in
and of themselves,
I mean, adding that
into the equation
is one of the hardest issues
to address in a war zone.
Disarmament is absolutely
critical to peace
and prosperity.
ADAM GREEN: And a lot of
the talk about armament
revolves around the
locations where the arms are.
But most of those guns are not
coming from sub-Saharan Africa
or the Middle East.
They're manufactured within
a couple kilometers of where
we're sitting right now.
The United States is the largest
arms exporter in the world.
And very recently with the
LAV deal in Saudi Arabia,
Canada had the
dubious distinction
of being declared the number two
arms dealer in the Middle East.
SAMANTHA NUTT: We did.
We just jumped to
number two, yeah.
ADAM GREEN: So does that
talk need to happen here?
Usually when we talk about
arms control and proliferation,
it's on the nuclear scale.
Like our militaries tend
to be obsessed with state
versus state conflict.
We're spending a trillion
dollars on the next fighter jet
program, the F-35.
That's the entire aid budget
of the world, roughly--
the NGO budget.
At what point does
arms control need
to start talking about
like 20 caliber things that
sit in someone's purse
in Texas but then can
be used to end dozens of lives
in somewhere like Sierra Leone?
SAMANTHA NUTT:
Well, I think you've
asked-- there are multiple
pieces to that question, which
is I think a very,
very important one.
On the issue of small arms
being available and accessible,
the problem with small
arms, many of them--
look at the Kalashnikov rifle.
They're virtually
indestructible.
They are the preferred
weapon of child soldiers.
ADAM GREEN: Yeah, it's
made to be buried in sand
and still keep working.
SAMANTHA NUTT: And so
if you make it here,
or you make it
the United States,
or it's made in Russia, or
in China, or wherever else,
once it gets into an
international market,
that is rarely its last stop.
And some of the ones
that I have seen,
and frankly, some
of the ones that
have been pointed at me
over the years by young men,
have been weapons that were
made even in the '50s and '60s.
They're very easy for
kids to load, and reload,
and to be trained to use.
So any weapon like that
that enters the marketplace,
it is a permanent problem.
It is not a temporary problem.
So that's one piece of it.
In terms of who contributes to
that, if you look at all weapon
sales-- so that includes
everything-- roughly 80%
of all weapons that are sold
in the world are manufactured
by-- the United States
is roughly half.
But then usually, it's England,
Germany, France, Russia, China.
So roughly 80% of them come
from none other than the five
permanent members of the United
Nations Security Council,
plus Germany.
Unfortunately now, Canada is
inching into that equation.
And I think it's
something that we have
to consider very carefully.
Because it does,
I think, undermine
our international reputation.
And we as Canadians can
sometimes-- you know,
we think that we're the
world's peacekeepers
and that we have this
reputation around the world
of human rights.
ADAM GREEN: We're like
number 58 on the list--
SAMANTHA NUTT: Yeah, and
we're not that anymore.
And if we want to have that
kind of prominence on the world
stage, and that credibility
and that reputation,
then I personally think that
we have to really question
whether or not our
arms exports are
consistent with those
values of promoting peace,
and security, and human rights.
Because you can go to any
war zone around the world
and know that that
is not the case.
ADAM GREEN: So until we can
do that, do you feel like you
guys at War Child
are kind of bailing
the Titanic with a bucket as
you try to educate people out
of this but almost
unlimited free weapons are
coming in the other side?
SAMANTHA NUTT: I think I
would look at that metaphor
slightly differently.
I feel like sometimes, you're
on the deck of the Titanic,
and you can see the iceberg.
You see kids and
the Syrian refugees
living in camps,
who are becoming
increasingly despondent because
they don't have opportunity.
You see southern
Sudanese families
who are selling their
children into arms groups
because they've run
out of resources
and because they're
increasingly desperate.
So you feel like you're on
the deck of the Titanic.
You can see the iceberg.
And you're going,
hey, everybody.
See iceberg.
See the iceberg, right?
And yet, it's not
enough to change course.
And that's the part that's
incredibly frustrating
for me and I think for
us as an organization.
Because you can feel it on the
ground when it's happening.
You can feel that shift, that
moment when people transition
from being hopeful to that
sense of hopelessness, that
sense that the world has
forgotten them, that nobody
cares about what's
happening to them, that when
that anger and that
resentment begin to build,
when they feel
increasingly desperate.
And it's no surprise
then that almost a year
within that moment,
you start to see people
putting their toddlers
into rubber dinghies
and trying to make it
across the Mediterranean Sea
to get them to safety.
ADAM GREEN: Yeah,
when that's the best
option for your
family, you things
are unspeakably horrible.
SAMANTHA NUTT: That's right.
That's the problem.
ADAM GREEN: So your
book is full of
unbelievably harrowing
stories, things
that you've gone through.
One of the things
that struck me was
the number of whip-smart,
incredibly brave educated women
from around the world that
you've worked with who have met
with horrible untimely ends.
You make a really good case
for the education of women
and girls around the world.
As a father of two little
girls, I don't even
think it's up for debate.
But how risky is it?
As we educate them, are
we sending more people
to the slaughter if we're
not educating people
on the other side, educating
the angry young men with the $10
automatic rifles, as to what
society could and should look
like if everyone was equal?
SAMANTHA NUTT: You
have to do both.
You don't have to do one
at the exclusion of others.
So educating girls
doesn't mean that that
comes at the expense
of educating boys.
And we found that and
War Child's found that
with our work all
around the world.
If you're not
investing in what we
call community-based
sensitization-- going
into those communities,
talking about the value
of girls' education,
demonstrating the importance
of women's economic
empowerment, proving
that to those communities
by having those women return
and they do become very
productive members.
And slowly, you see people's
minds and attitudes change.
And you can't go in there
with this giant sort
of imperialist agenda and your
finger wagging, and saying,
it's got to be this
way and that's wrong.
Because if you do that,
you're going to be shut out
and shut down.
And you may in fact put many
of those young girls or women
that you want to be
helping at risk by virtue
of behaving in that fashion.
ADAM GREEN: And there's
been some of that.
Madonna had an education
effort that ended in flames,
and Oprah and a few others.
You offer some pretty
withering criticism
in your book of people who just
come in with an outside agenda
into a local area and say,
this is how it should be.
How do you guys operate
differently at War Child?
How do you make sure
you're not doing that?
SAMANTHA NUTT: Well, for us,
98% of our staff are local.
And we have several hundred
staff around the world.
So these are folks who
come from war zones who
are working for us
within those countries
to build our programs,
to identify the needs,
to evaluate them, to
make sure that we're
asking the right
questions and that we have
that level of community
legitimacy and acceptance
before we even start.
We are, as I said, we're not
an emergency organization.
So we don't go in there
and say, well, we're
in the business of blankets.
So here's your blanket.
That's not what we do.
We go in, and we will have
a one, two-year process
of information gathering;
of collaboration;
of conversation with
local community groups,
grassroots civil
society organizations,
UN agencies, other
organizations on the ground,
to say, OK, what contribution
can we make here?
What are the needs?
What needs are not being met?
What is the overall risk to
children in that community
by not meeting those needs?
And how can we help you?
And I think that that
fundamentally is the question.
If you go in and say, this is
how we're going to help you,
that's how aid goes wrong.
If you go in and say, tell me
about what's going on here.
How can we help you?
And you and you
build it, and you
were critical in that
process, and ask yourself
the hard questions,
it doesn't mean
you'll always get it right.
But it means you're more
likely to get it right.
ADAM GREEN: So come with
more question marks,
less exclamation points.
SAMANTHA NUTT: Absolutely.
And you see that
in a lot of crises.
You see a lot of grandstanding.
And for me over the years, you
know, I've been in this work
for 20 years.
It's kind of been the
bane of my existence.
People who have no experience
in Iraq and they've
been there for two
days, and they stand up
and they say, children
are starving here
And you look at them, and
you go, where the hell
have you been?
Yes, they have been starving
there for last 10 years,
actually, thanks
to the sanctions.
But--
ADAM GREEN: Into
the ninth inning.
SAMANTHA NUTT: Yeah, welcome.
ADAM GREEN: We've been playing
this baseball game for a while.
SAMANTHA NUTT: That's right.
ADAM GREEN: You also offer
some pretty heavy criticism
of well-meaning do-gooders.
How can we, in the
privileged West,
help folks that
actually is productive?
You're pretty critical of
things like voluntourism,
of ping-pong ball funding
where fund the government that
funds the UN that then funds
their local region that
then funds an NGO.
And by the time someone in
need actually gets the money,
it's like small
pennies on the dollar.
What can we do that's actually
effective from this end?
SAMANTHA NUTT: Well, there
are a number of things.
I mean, the more
directly you can
contribute to an organization
that is working on the ground
and with those
grassroots partners, that
means that your money is
going to go much further.
So every time, if
[INAUDIBLE] organization
that then has an
international arm, and then it
gets kind of divided
and divided and divided,
and it will end up
at the field level,
the impact of your
dollar is diluted.
So that's something
to be very mindful of,
is to always make sure.
Ask organizations, what is
their programming model?
Are they a directly
implementing agency?
Because that's
very, very critical.
The second piece of it is
so much of our aid money
is wasted because of one thing.
And that one thing
is inconsistency.
Because we see a
crisis in the news.
We might write a check once,
or go online and donate.
And then here we are five, six,
seven years later going, well,
why don't things get any
better in places like Haiti?
I mean, these kinds
of challenges,
you're really talking
about structural deficits.
And like anything
else, it takes time.
And so we know here, if you're
talking about education,
it's not enough to send a kid to
school for a week, or a month,
or even a year.
It is a long-term investment.
So you're far better
off as a donor
giving a-- and
this is always when
my head director of
development has a heart attack.
But now he's going,
don't say this.
But you're far better off
giving a smaller amount of money
on a regular basis than you
are writing a check once
and then forgetting about it.
It allows organizations
to properly
plan, to implement in areas that
the world has often forgotten
and has shown less interest in.
It allows you to direct those
resources to the highest need
environments and
not be so subjected
to the whims and mercies of
the media cycle, for example.
So that's one way to do it.
Don't give things
like hard goods--
clothes, and books,
and all that stuff.
It won't get there
in time to be useful.
It's too expensive to
ship and distribute.
ADAM GREEN: Yeah, cash flies
a lot cheaper than books.
SAMANTHA NUTT: Cash
is a lot better.
You know, it's a much
better way of doing it.
And in fact, many
organizations now
are looking at cash
vouchers for refugees
because then they can
make their own decisions
around what their family needs.
We have this very
paternalistic approach.
It's like, no, you're
going to have 10
bags of rice and six blankets.
And a lot of those
refugee families
are sitting there saying,
actually, I don't eat rice
and I've got enough blankets.
But that's not how we do it.
ADAM GREEN: It's very hot here.
I don't need more blankets.
SAMANTHA NUTT: And
so now we're changing
that attitude and making it
certainly more empowering,
but also some recognizing the
value of cash contributions.
And gifts in kind like labor are
extremely valuable, especially
to organizations that might
have headquarters locally.
People have various
skills that they
can bring to our organization.
But that volunteer work is
most helpful to us here.
Unless you are a
seasoned expert who
understands development,
understands the context,
understands the risks
involved, frankly,
when you're going overseas
and doing this kind of work,
you might be taking
those opportunities away
from local community
groups, which
is something to be mindful of.
A lot of it is busy
work philanthropy.
Do you really need to go
and repaint that classroom?
Or is there somebody
else that, with money
you save on your ticket,
could be hired locally--
ADAM GREEN: Perhaps
a local painter.
SAMANTHA NUTT: --to
paint that classroom.
And then the second
piece of it is
it's a huge security
risk for most agencies.
So sometimes, the
better way for you
to contribute-- in fact, often,
the better way to contribute
is to be a donor and to
help here if you can.
ADAM GREEN: Excellent.
So I want to bring you back
to Google for a second.
We have this mantra,
don't be evil.
We all like to
think of ourselves
as really good people.
But pretty much all of
us have a tiny slice
of unspeakable evil
sitting in our pocket
right now-- the minerals
that go into these,
particularly coltan
mined in the DRC
is an engine of human misery.
Why do you think the
industry collectively
can't get on top of that?
We did it with diamonds.
Why not other minerals?
SAMANTHA NUTT: It's a lot more
complicated than diamonds.
And I'm not offering
that up as an excuse
but more of an explanation.
I mean, you can take a
diamond and look at it
under a microscope and know
exactly where it came from.
And so conflict tracing in
that sort of environment
became somewhat easier
than with coltan.
I mean, coltan, it's estimated
that the Congo contains
between 60% to 80% of the
world's coltan deposits.
It is readily smuggled
across Congo's borders
and ends up in
international markets.
It generates hundreds of
millions of dollars in revenues
and often use towards arms sales
for various Congolese-backed
military groups
and militia groups
operating in that unstable
part of the world.
But by the time it gets
to your cell phone,
you have no idea whether
it's Congolese coltan
or any other kind of coltain.
Chances are, just
based on probability,
it is Congolese coltan.
I think, to be honest,
this is an issue
that the industry itself
needs to actively get
behind and start to look at
what solutions are viable
and make the most sense.
A straight-out
ban, unfortunately,
follows the law of
unintended consequences.
And under the Dodd-Frank
legislation in the United
States that required sort
of more accountability
and companies not to
use conflict minerals,
what happened was a
lot of American firms
closed their mines that put
a lot of artisanal miners out
of work.
And what happens when
you have no employment?
You join a militia group because
they are the only employer--
so again, the laws of
unintended consequences.
What we really need
is sectoral reform.
We need to look at how you
fix the climate of impunity
at the same time.
You have to come
at it from a number
of different perspectives.
It can be done, but none
of that will ever happen
unless one other thing happens.
And that's that
the industry itself
has to be prepared
to confront this
in an honest and
transparent way.
ADAM GREEN: The tech industry,
or the mining industry,
or both?
SAMANTHA NUTT: The entire
industry-- tech and mining
because the two really
go hand in hand.
ADAM GREEN: Yeah, and we're
sitting in a very unique place.
We're at a big tech company.
And within a 10-block
radius of this office
is the highest concentration
of mining company headquarters
in the world.
So we might be, in this
office, somewhat uniquely
placed to tackle this issue.
SAMANTHA NUTT: You are uniquely
And every time any
effort has been
brought about to
introduce legislation
around this that
would force, frankly,
mining companies to be more
accountable and transparent,
it's been met by very heavy
lobbying, expensive lobbying,
on the part of those
mining industries.
And it has been shut down.
ADAM GREEN: Yeah, bill
C-300 got shut down.
SAMANTHA NUTT: That's right.
ADAM GREEN: Very
narrowly, though.
It was only like 10 votes.
SAMANTHA NUTT: And
then Paul Dewar
was trying to
introduce legislation
as well, who is the
NDP foreign affairs
critic who lost a seat
recently in the election.
But he also had taken
steps around this issue.
And again, I don't want to--
the answers are not simple.
It does need a
development approach.
It needs a governance approach.
It needs a diplomatic approach.
But all of that
can happen as long
as there is acknowledgement from
the industry and a willingness
to lead change.
And if we can even
start there and begin
to have those conversations--
ADAM GREEN: Just recognize
that we have a problem.
SAMANTHA NUTT: Recognize
we have a problem,
and that's exactly what
happened with conflict diamonds.
For a while, the industry was
like, there isn't a problem.
There isn't a problem.
And they ran from it and
they lobbied against it.
And then finally, they
said, we do have a problem.
The Kimberly Process
is imperfect.
The fact that Zimbabwean
diamonds were not
considered conflict diamonds
is a huge gaping hole
in that process.
But it's a step in
the right direction.
And even if it's
imperfect to start,
at least we're
making that effort.
ADAM GREEN: Yeah, do something.
Something is better
than nothing.
SAMANTHA NUTT: Something is
usually better than nothing.
ADAM GREEN: Usually.
SAMANTHA NUTT: Usually.
ADAM GREEN: That's fair.
So I want to change
gears a little
and go to you personally.
You're a physician, an
author, an assistant professor
at the U of T, a
mother, a board member,
and the founder and executive
director of War Child Canada.
And you're also in the midst
of setting up War Child US.
When exactly do you sleep?
SAMANTHA NUTT: Between 3:00
and 5:00 in the morning.
No, sleep is
overrated, is it not?
ADAM GREEN: No, it's not.
It is a glorious,
glorious part of life.
You should try it more often.
SAMANTHA NUTT: No
one is claiming
I'm doing all of those
things well, by the way.
You know what?
I mean, it's one
of those things--
and this is going
to sound so trite,
and I apologize in advance.
But when you do what
you love, there really
is no distinction
between your on-time
and your off-time, right?
So when I'm reading, I'm
reading about foreign policy
and global issues.
When I'm sitting around
the dinner table,
we're discussing and
debating these issues.
And you know, and I have a
limitless passion for the work
that War Child does
around the world.
And so not championing
that, it feels
like I'm just being disconnected
from myself in many ways.
So for me, I'm not
tired by what I do.
I'm energized by it.
I get more tired when
I'm not doing it,
when I feel that I
haven't done enough.
And that's when I
feel most frustrated.
ADAM GREEN: It's like
the ultimate substitute
for coffee for you.
SAMANTHA NUTT: It is, yes--
well, coffee or-- I was
going to say wine there,
but-- [LAUGHS] --but I
still like my wine.
The--
ADAM GREEN: These aren't
mutually exclusive.
SAMANTHA NUTT:
Yeah, that's right.
ADAM GREEN: You can
still have wine.
SAMANTHA NUTT: That's right.
No, I'm lucky, you know.
I get to do what I'm
passionate about,
and we can't all
say that in life.
ADAM GREEN: That's fantastic.
Do you guys have any
questions in the audience?
I want to be cognizant
and not just hog the mic
the whole time.
Yeah, Margo, just go just
go up to the mic if you can.
[INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: You talked
a little bit earlier
about Canadian's perception
as being peacekeepers when
the reality is that we are a
big part and a growing part
of the distribution of weapons.
I'm curious if you've
had a chance to sit down
with our relatively new
government, Prime Minister
Trudeau or anybody
in his circle,
and what their view is
on where we are today
and trying to correct
some of these issues
that we might be
contributing towards.
SAMANTHA NUTT: That's
an excellent question.
And I have had some
of those conversations
and they are certainly ongoing.
And I have testified
at the state committee
of foreign affairs
over the last couple
of years on a few of
these related issues.
I think one of the most
significant things,
though, that Canada can
do and should be doing
is signing the
Arms Trade Treaty.
The Arms Trade Treaty was
initially a Canadian led effort
to try to bring about
international binding
legislation concerning the
sale, the manufacturing,
the stockpiling and the transfer
of small and light weapons
in the world.
And about two years
ago now, in fact,
it finally passed through
the United Nations.
And more than 115 countries
have signed on to it.
Unfortunately, along
with Russia and China,
Canada has not yet signed
the Arms Trade Treaty.
And because we missed
the first deadline,
now we have to pass a whole
series of pieces of legislation
before were even
eligible to sign it.
And there is-- and I'm going to
be very, very clear on this one
point.
There is no way that if we had
signed the Arms Trade Treaty,
we would have been
able to approve
that $15 billion arms deal to
Saudi Arabia, or to Thailand
subsequently.
So now, the current
government has
committed to signing
the Arms Trade Treaty,
but there has been no official
deadline prescribed in relation
to that.
And because it is contingent
upon these other pieces
of legislation
falling into place,
I don't know how long
that's going to take,
or if it is even going to
be during this particular
parliamentary cycle.
I hope that it is.
It Is absolutely the
right thing to do.
And as we talk about
reengaging with the world
and revitalizing our
multilateralist traditions
as a country, we certainly
need to understand
that our absence from
the Arms Trade Treaty
and the reputation, in many
instances, of our mining sector
and some of the violations
of human rights and labor
violations in relation to
that, that that has really
thrown some of our
credibility into question.
And so if we really
want to get there,
if we want to still be seen as
that strong, vibrant, ethical
force in the world,
then we do have
to get some of these
other pieces in order.
So hopefully, they'll see
that as one in the same.
ADAM GREEN: We have a lot of
good intentions as a nation.
We need to start
actually acting on them.
SAMANTHA NUTT: Yeah.
But we've made some
strides, though.
We have.
ADAM GREEN: Margo, who
could you ask, just
because there are people on VC.
AUDIENCE: And what
was the reasoning
for missing the
first opportunity?
SAMANTHA NUTT: It was under
the last government, the Harper
government.
And they did not sign
the arms trade treaty
when they had that opportunity.
And in fact, the domestic
gun lobby in Canada
did a pretty good job.
Even though it has nothing to
do with domestic gun ownership,
they did a pretty good
job of making people
feel that it was an effort-- the
NRA did the same in the United
States-- an effort to control
domestic arms sales and use.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
SAMANTHA NUTT: It's like
anything else with the arms
industry.
There's a lot more
propaganda and irrational
thinking out there
on this subject
than there is fact
and honest appraisal.
ADAM GREEN: And you
have a very small number
of interests, both
numerically and monetary,
who seem to hold the
entire agenda hostage.
In the US, there's a
huge debate going on.
I think they may actually
still be debating in Congress.
They had a filibuster all night.
The majority of Americans
support efforts like this.
The majority of Canadians
But a tiny group
of vested interests
can block that legislation.
How important do you
think political activism
is on the part of
individuals-- writing
to our members of parliament,
writing to our senators,
writing to our congresspeople?
SAMANTHA NUTT: I think
it's absolutely critical.
Politicians are swayed
by public opinion.
And--
ADAM GREEN: Strongly worded
letters really do work.
SAMANTHA NUTT: And there
isn't a politician out there
that isn't concerned
about re-election.
So if you have enough people
who are mounting an opposition
to a particular policy, a
particular point of view,
politicians are going
to listen to that.
Part of the reason why the Arms
Trade Treaty didn't get signed
is that there simply wasn't
enough public interest
or concern or outcry that
we hadn't signed it yet.
And that's a great shame.
And I think the same applies
to the United States.
When you have the
majority of Americans
who are at least
committed to introducing
certain aspects of gun control
legislation around particularly
semiautomatic weapons
like the AR-15, people who
are on a terrorist
watch list-- we're
talking about people who have
a very clear mental health
history that would be
deemed to be high risk.
I mean, that is a
public safety issue.
ADAM GREEN: People on the
terrorist no-fly list.
SAMANTHA NUTT: People on
the terrorist no-fly list.
That is a public safety issue.
And they are right to be
shaming and embarrassing those
legislators who cannot get
behind what the majority
of Americans want.
ADAM GREEN: Yeah,
even here in Canada,
we had a member
of parliament who
was making the case the AR-15
is a perfectly safe device when
handled properly.
So is heroin.
So is plutonium.
We don't let you
have that either.
And also made the case that it's
a great deer hunting weapon.
I've never seen anybody
go hunting with an AR-15.
SAMANTHA NUTT: And
that's a great point.
And I would add to that too.
People will often say, well, if
people want to kill each other,
they're going to find a way.
And they will cite
different wars
around the world in
which machetes were used
and other things to slaughter
hundreds of thousands
of people.
But the truth is that in
almost every instance,
it's having access to those
small weapons that in fact also
facilitated that
particular slaughter.
Because usually,
it's people with arms
that are able to then
move the populations
or control or prevent
anybody who is trying
to stop that from happening.
So the two often
go hand in hand.
ADAM GREEN: And the case
for making it easier
isn't a good idea, right?
SAMANTHA NUTT: No.
No.
Exactly.
ADAM GREEN: They
might find a way,
but there's not
a lot of kids who
get like killed by
stray strangling.
SAMANTHA NUTT:
Well, that's right.
ADAM GREEN: That's not a thing.
SAMANTHA NUTT: That's right.
And you have a
much better chance
of being able to
stop that person.
The more automatic that
weapon is, the more violent
that weapon is, the
greater the destruction.
ADAM GREEN: Excellent.
Any other audience questions
or Dory questions, Vera?
AUDIENCE: So here at Google, we
have employee resource groups
of which the largest
is Women at Google.
There's a pretty strong chapter
in our office led by Margo here
and Nancy sitting
right next to her.
So the first time
that I saw you speak
was at the WXN
summit in November.
You were the keynote at
the awards gala that night.
And we were all just like
in love with you after that.
We thought you had a
lot of great perspective
on life in general.
And what I loved
about the way that you
spoke was that it was not,
oh, I'm speaking to the girls.
This is like among us girls.
You just had a great
perspective in life in general.
That being said, I think you
had a lot to say about what it's
like being in your role,
and going through your life
being you, being a woman and
having some of the barriers
that you did.
So I'd love if you could kind of
talk about that for this group.
SAMANTHA NUTT: Well, thank you.
And it's nice to see you again.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
SAMANTHA NUTT: Look, there's
no question that being a woman
and doing this
kind of work comes
with its own set of challenges.
We're in environments
around the world
where there's a tremendous
amount of sexual violence,
huge amount of harassment--
I mean, I've personally
experienced a great deal
of that myself-- and risk,
and then trying to
juggle everything.
I never use the word balance.
Balance for me is
always such a cliche.
Because I, without exaggeration,
wake up every day and deal
with what's on fire.
And if I can put
out those fires,
that is a banner day for me.
So balance, I
think, is something
that is sort of a mythology.
You find balance where
you find leprechauns
and rainbow-colored unicorns.
ADAM GREEN: Sounds
like a fabulous place.
SAMANTHA NUTT: But
you know, so that it
does come with certain risks.
And for me, the only way
that I have discovered
to contend with that is
just to stare them down,
to get back up, and
to get back in there
and to persevere, to defy.
And I've been doing
that my entire life.
And you get that, as
a girl, from the time
that you're this big.
Girls can't play in the park.
Girls can't do this.
Girls can't do that.
Well, girls can do those things.
And girls are
doing those things.
And we're going to show you
that we can do them better.
And that's the message that I
try to convey to young women
all the time, which
is to speak up,
to speak out, to be undaunted,
to don't seek permissions.
In my opinion,
permissions are only
sought by those who
lack imagination.
And don't be afraid to screw up.
And don't worry so much about
whether people like you.
I'm sure there's an entire
fleet of people out there
who can't stand me.
And I know there is
because, in fact, I
hear from them on Twitter
quite often, especially
some of those NRA folks.
They love me.
And I think that if we
don't hear enough, really,
women's voices.
And we don't role model
enough, and we don't
mentor that enough, I think.
And so for all of
you here as women
who are in the tech
industry, I think
it's really incumbent on
you, too, to be out there
and to be talking
about your experiences
and to be getting other
young women involved,
and to be defying
those stereotypes.
Because when I first
started in this work,
there were hardly any women
going in and out of war zones.
There were hardly
any-- you know,
war was always seen as
traditionally a male domain.
And now, I'm astonished every
time I walk into the office,
and we have so many more women
in our office than we do men.
And they're definitely the
visible minority in our office.
And that's great.
That is great,
especially when you're
talking about working with
civilians in war zones,
that usually, the ones who
are most impacted by war
are civilians, primarily
women and children.
So having women on the front
lines of those conversations
trying to do something about
it is critical to our success
and to eventually
eradicating the problem.
ADAM GREEN: In your
book in the intro,
you mentioned that
you don't think
that war is a part of
the human condition
and that there is hope.
After reading it and
listening to your TED talk,
I'm just struck by how
complicated these issues are.
What keeps you hopeful?
SAMANTHA NUTT: A
couple of things.
But I would say I don't
fear that complexity.
I think that part of it
is there aren't always
easy fixes and easy answers.
And we mislead people when we
pretend that that isn't true.
ADAM GREEN: Despite what
campaign promises say.
SAMANTHA NUTT: Despite
what campaign promises
are out there, right?
And I think that for all
of us, as we move forward,
it is important to be more
sophisticated around what works
and what doesn't work.
And that it is complicated
and it's time for us
to embrace that complexity.
So I would say partly that.
But for me,
ultimately what I find
most hopeful is that every day
in War Child in our office,
we are surrounded
by people who are
a testament to what can
be done with compassion,
and some ingenuity, and
concern, and a sense
of strong global citizenship.
We hear from people
who are in our programs
where it really has
changed their lives.
We hear from staff who
run those programs who
helped build those programs
just how important our work is
to their community, and
how respected they feel,
and how engaged they
feel, and that ours
is a true partnership-- that
we're not coming in and telling
them what to do, but
we're asking them
what they want to do.
And that they feel
valued in the process.
And so whenever I find
myself extremely frustrated,
which is often-- and it's
never about the things
that you would expect.
We're dealing with
security situations
all the time which
are very frustrating.
But it's often seeing
a fantastic program
like the one we have
in eastern Congo
that survives on
fumes because it's
so hard to mobilize public
interest for that war
now that it's almost 20 years
old despite how devastating it
has been.
That's the stuff that
keeps me up at night.
But I get up, and I
pushed through that sense
of cynicism and frustration
because people depend on us.
And it always has seemed
very self-indulgent to me
to say, oh, this
work is exhausting.
I want to do it anymore.
I mean, we've got people
around the world that get shot
at on their way to
work, whose children
can't go more than two blocks
because they'll be raped.
In South Sudan where all of
our staff and program partners
had to flee to
the refugee camps.
And within two days of them
arriving at the refugee camps,
they said, we're
going to keep going.
And we went, well,
hang on a second.
We're still trying to figure
out where the stuff is.
The whole office has
been burned and torched.
They're like, no, no.
We're here now.
We're good to go.
And that is extraordinary.
And it's breathtaking
when you experience it.
And you know, it makes
me really hopeful.
And that's why I
get up every day.
ADAM GREEN: That's fantastic.
Vera, how are we doing for time?
VERA: [INAUDIBLE].
ADAM GREEN: OK, excellent.
So in that case, I'm
going to leave it on that.
Everyone here, I encourage
you to take Samantha's request
seriously.
We have a donation
matching program at Google.
You can set it up so that
part of every single paycheck
goes to an organization like War
Child to help in conflict zones
that people may have
forgotten about,
that they're no longer
in the headlines.
Write those strongly
worded letters
to your members of parliament.
Try to make that difference.
And we have some books,
I think, at the back--
"Damned Nation" is
a fantastic read.
And definitely check out the
TED Talk as well on ted.com.
SAMANTHA NUTT: Thanks, everyone.
ADAM GREEN: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]